the growing popularity of meal kits is
one reason the restaurant industry has
struggled recently in the last year one
in four adults use services that supply
recipes and ingredients that you can
cook at home it's now estimated to be a
more than two billion dollar industry
Peter Greenberg reveals techniques that
savvy restaurant owners are using to
fight back have you ever noticed that so
many fast food chains use red and yellow
in their logos research shows this color
scheme is an intentional stimulant it
signifies happiness energy and hunger
they subtly tell consumers enjoy
yourself get in and get out now it's not
just color successful restaurants have
an arsenal of tools at their disposal to
tantalize your senses and keep you
coming back when you walk into a
restaurant you may not notice the tempo
of the music the table shape or the menu
layout but those details are influencing
your entire dining experience from what
you'll order to how much you'll pay to
how long you'll stay once you enter a
restaurant there's a pretty good chance
that to some degree intentionally or
unintentionally you're being manipulated
Stephens a core of the Institute of
Culinary Education spent more than 25
years developing and managing
restaurants hopefully a restaurant is
taking you by the hand I'd like to call
it mind over mouth and making things
happen in you that are gonna make a your
experience great without you really
knowing about it and be making it good
for the restaurant where they're selling
you more and making it a better
situation for them let's start with the
menu restaurants place either profitable
or signature items in the upper right
hand corner because that's where most
consumers look first boxes or brackets
also capture your attention and beware
of what the industry calls anchors
expensive plates are strategically
positioned to make other nearby dishes
look like a good value the faster the
tempo of the music the faster you eat
faster you eat the faster you chew the
faster you eat and studies have said
that the energy sometimes even leads to
more consumption if we want to have
lighting that makes people feel
attractive these particulars aren't lost
on restaurateur Danny Meyer
whose ability to craft the dining
experience is more of an art than a
science
you want to have a variety of table
shapes because you don't want people's
eyes or their experiences to get boring
he recently reopened his 30-year old New
York City eatery Union Square cafe in a
new spot every detail has been carefully
considered the table is always gonna be
ever so slightly wider than it is deep
it drives me crazy when I go to a
restaurant and the person I came with is
further away from me than the two people
on either side of me with whom I didn't
come and noise noise is a lot like salt
in the hands of a chef too much is wrong
and too little is wrong the stakes for
restaurants are higher than ever it used
to be that if you wanted to stay home
you were cooking today you can order
food by pushing a button on your
smartphone you can cook half the food by
ordering a meal kit so if you're gonna
go out you have to have a compelling
reason you have to have a compelling
reason so to be a successful restaurant
you actually have to look at this as an
emotional asset purely when people
choose to come back or not they may say
it has to do with what you put on the
plate or what you pour into the glass I
guarantee you that the decision to
return has almost everything to do with
how did we make you feel how does Danny
Meyer want you to feel like you've gone
out but have also come home and
restaurant owners today have more tools
than ever
historically with restaurants
kind of have to make decisions based on
gut feeling Julie and Golia is one of
the partners behind the mercury in
Atlanta spot city market he's using
data-driven software to curate his
customer experience for example after
introducing a brunch menu a sales
analytics program called up serve showed
him he was losing customers the
retention rate had gone down because the
price point probably wasn't right for
the market and so we changed her price
point and now the retention rate and the
sales have gone up exponentially we did
something right and his reservation
system is fueled by customer preferences
before you come in we know that you like
this you don't like that you hate
sitting at a particular type of table
and if I have the option to make that
work for you it's amazing information
and amazing as that is it all really
gets down to the basics here's a tip
from Danny Meyer the next time you're
looking at a menu consider ordering a
side dish as a starter instead of an
appetizer restaurants typically charge
more for appetizers and side dishes and
it could be an equally satisfying
experience oh that's a good tip listen I
mean I didn't know all that went into
how you sit in the restaurant but I do
know Danny Meyer's food is very good
Shake Shack Shake Shack starting with
Shake Shack but his food is very good
but the acoustics and the lighting make
a difference all right I tried to make a
resident ate at a place try to make a
reservation for later they already have
file ready for me okay let's put your
croque it put it in your customer
profile which some may find a little
creepy but you know for that place the
best thing I thought Peter said it makes
you feel like you've gone out but you've
also come home that's how you want to
feel very nice